if you're looking to save as much money
as possible when filing your taxes this
year knowing this one number will help
your adjusted gross income or AGI
adjusted gross income is the starting
point for your tax return it's a a
common measure of income that the IRS
uses and the government uses to
determine how much money you've made
over the course of the past year so to
demystify your tax return we break down
how to calculate your AGI and how this
one number impacts your finances
[Music]
the IRS defines adjusted gross income or
AGI as your gross income minus
adjustments to income it's commonly
referred to as the line above the line
you have two things your gross income
and your adjustments your gross income
is a combination of your wages stock
dividends capital gains and any other
income you might have like business
profits adjustments refer to things like
interest on student loan payments
contributions to some retirement
accounts and expenses you may have as a
teacher just to name a few these
adjustments are commonly referred to as
above-the-line deductions and once you
subtract them from your gross income
you've got your AGI
so once you've calculated it why does it
matter let's take a look at Olivia and
calculate her gross income Olivia earned
sixty thousand dollars a year from her
day job as a chemist after subtracting
her 401K contributions and health
insurance premiums which aren't taxed
her taxable wage is fifty seven thousand
dollars a year
she also rented out her extra bedroom
which brought in a net total of six
thousand dollars and lastly Olivia
bought and sold stocks within the past
year profiting a thousand dollars
because she held the stocks for only a
few months her profit is considered a
short-term capital gain and is taxed at
the ordinary income rate meaning it's
less complicated for our purposes so all
together Olivia's gross income comes out
to sixty four thousand dollars
but remember if you have other sources
of income like from freelancing or side
hustles you'll need to add those to your
gross income as well now to find
Olivia's AGI she has to subtract the
adjustments from her gross income there
are quite a few possibilities here like
educator expenses and self-employed
health insurance one of those
adjustments is interest on student loan
debt Olivia has private student loan
debt and made payments throughout the
year so she can subtract up to twenty
five hundred dollars bringing her AGI to
sixty one thousand five hundred dollars
this brings us back to why knowing your
adjusted gross income matters after your
AGI has been calculated you can check
for any tax credits you may qualify for
adjusted gross income is used by
Congress to set parameters for various
tax breaks to basically ensure that
they're going to lower a middle-income
people and then aren't fully available
to very high income people there are a
lot of tax credits available for example
you have the something called the Savers
credit which is essentially a government
match for retirement contributions and
you have the earned income credit which
is the government's main program for
assisting low and middle income families
last year 31 million eligible workers
and families benefited from the Earned
Income Tax Credit averaging Savings of
more than two thousand dollars there are
also tax credits with eligibility tied
to AGI for students and parents like the
American Opportunity tax credit or child
tax credit but these situations don't
apply to Olivia so she doesn't get to
claim tax breaks based on AGI this year
after you calculate your tax credits you
can take deductions and determine your
actual tax bill the more you understand
about how the tax code Works how it keys
off of this number the easier it can be
to figure out why you're getting to the
bottom line number you're getting if you
hire an accountant or use other Tax
Services you may not need to calculate
your AGI to figure out how to save with
it but no matter whether your tax taxes
are in your hands or someone else's this
little number on line 11 plays a key
role in your financial life